hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in nikka
mechanics book seven in the course of
discussing the phenomena of lack or loss
of self-control that is across here
Aristotle is going to bring up something
that he discusses at other points in his
works never quite enough never quite
what we want so in a way is both
illuminating and also puzzling and has
given rise to a lot of discussion by my
commentators and scholars for years and
they have a thing that idea is what we
call the practical syllogism a practical
syllogism is a mode like that put here
waiting engaging in practical or moral
reasoning a syllogism itself assuming
osmosis is a particular form of
reasoning or argumentation and Aristotle
tells us a bit more about these actually
quite a bit more about these in terms of
theoretical or speculative reasoning in
some of his other works when it comes to
practical matters we can and we do in
fact will often make arguments about
them deliberation about what we want to
do quite often involved
articulating why it is that we want to
do something and trying to convince
ourselves or trying to convince others
that one one passes is better than the
others under the possibilities now this
term saw a ghost most that Aristotle is
using some people take it to always mean
exactly the same form of argument which
is that it has three statements or
propositions that are arranged in a
certain way to them being premises one
of them being the conclusion arranged
more or less like this these are two
premises that's the conclusion of the
syllogism my own view on this and I'm
not the only person who holds this is
that that cannot possibly be the entire
story because as we you'll often see we
need a whole bunch of other premises
coming in in order to fill it out
Aristotle also talks in the rhetoric
about you know empty memes and which
which are syllogisms that are lacking
one of the terms where you have to can
supply it yourself he also discusses
both of them word and in several other
places including the Nicomachean ethics
the role of the middle term that
connects the major and minor premise
together and you know how a person finds
that he talks about facility in deriving
or constructing syllogisms there's a lot
more involved in this topic but but for
the purposes of this video I want to try
to stick as closely with what Aristotle
is actually giving us here in nikka
McKean ethics book 7 and then you can
decide whether it's really sufficient
for a moral or practical argumentation
or whether the account needs to be
filled out initially so going back to
this traditionally in a syllogism there
are three statements there's what is
called the major premise which Aristotle
says deals with things that are
universal we're general because remember
in ethics we have to keep in mind that
we're talking about things as they
generally happen not as they always by
necessity happen you have a minor
premise as well and the minor premise is
he's going to say deals with the
particulars which are in in large
respect a manner for what we can call
perception or observation by spaces by
the way you should probably also take a
look at the core concept video on
intellect or news understanding because
that will will also give you some of the
information about us now you know the
you know regular syllogism a a now
impractical 1/1 which is not as
aristotle says in intake types proc
tickets in in practical matters you know
what we're doing is we have a major
premise which is some sort of statement
X's why another statements as well
another premise why is Z and we have to
get a conclusion which is something that
we know and we assent to X is Z right
there we're talking about something like
was Comi tivity transitivity
transitivity in the case of practical
syllogisms Aristotle says that they
actually culminate in not in a statement
but they culminate in an action they
move us to doing things this is one of
the areas where we might want to say
that seems a little far-fetched perhaps
that's not always the case sometimes
maybe they result in the imperative hey
you should go do that thing because we
know that people engage in reasoning and
don't follow their their reasoning we're
talking about this precisely in the
context of the cross yeah but in any
case he says when the two premises are
combined just as a theoretic reasoning
the mind is compelled to affirm the
resulting conclusion so in the case of
practical premises you are forced at
once and uses that
who's that want us to do it so the
example that he uses there which I think
can be very helpful for illustrating
this is all sweet things are to be
tasted so you know let's assume that you
actually accept that I promise
probably shouldn't because he says at
the same time you know you've also got
in mind don't eat those sorts of things
right that thing over there is sweet
therefore go taste that thing and if
Aristotle if the account that is giving
here is actually the complete one then
you don't actually hear like a voice in
your head saying go taste that thing you
just go and taste that thing
likewise you know we could say you know
all honors are beat are to be desired
that's an honor I should desire that
honor where I should pursue that honor
however we almost we want to put it now
this one already by its own nature what
I thought about it illustrates the fact
that there can't just be two premises
why how do you know that thing over
there is sweet you know something to be
sweet because you actually have tasted
it right or you are going by some other
index for example that thing over there
is a strawberry and strawberries are
sweet going by my previous experience so
I should go over and taste that thing
most likely what we want to think about
is that these these propositions that
form the premises could probably be
expanded into a whole much longer
argument you know using some background
knowledge involving some other
inferences going on and it's useful to
do that because it
might actually accomplish the to cyllage
eyes as Aristotle says uses that as a
verb to cyllage eyes better but in any
case this is how Aristotle depicts the
practical syllogism perhaps it's
somewhat different in the way that it
really works compared to this model here
that we have but this model at least
gives us something that we can start
with and in the case of trying to make
sense out of what he's saying in nikka
McKay an ethics book 7 about Achrafieh
this is what you want to have in mind